I'm joined today by Amanda Marcotte she
is a senior political writer for
salon.com focuses on covering the
American right everything from Fox News
and right-wing radio to denialism of
climate change the gun lobby and so many
other things her new book is called
troll nation and there's a lot of very
very interesting stuff in it Amanda I
want to start if it's okay with you you
were involved in covering this movement
known as gamergate several years ago
sort of at the same time when I was
doing some interviews related to the
subject and you've pointed out or at
least sort of drawn a parallel between
what led to the creation of gamergate
and also the forces that ultimately led
to the election of Donald Trump which I
find super interesting because it's
something I've been saying and you often
hear from the gamergate crowd like
listen most most people involved with
the movement or left-wing can you talk a
little bit about the what you see is the
overlap and similarities in those two
groups yeah I mean in in both cases what
you see is a lot of people that have
what you would call white male
conservative you know of various degrees
identity politics and they resent you
know the they resent a changing
demographic of whether it's just video
games or the country generally where
women people of color immigrants are
getting to have not only more in numbers
but also more power and we're getting a
backlash and a lot of that backlash is
justified by characterizing this new
incursion of you know diverse people as
politically correct social justice
warriors so you know the kind of the
reactionary crowd paints themselves as a
victim they say that they'll often even
say they're not racist or sexist that
they just don't like the social justice
warriors with all their demands and
their political correctness pressing
themselves on you so I see a parallel in
that I I think you know these anti
political correctness narratives are a
way to try to create a victim narrative
out of what is actually just the
reactionary movement trying to retain
white male straight white male privilege
in American society or videogames
there's a couple different spots there
that I think are fascinating and really
exposed some double standards and
they'll just pick one of them which is
identity politics then then we can get
to the issues of free speech and
censorship which I think are also
important I've been critical as someone
on the left of some of the ways in which
identity politics has been employed in
in different elements which I think are
not good for the left at the same time
others that I see criticizing identity
politics from the right seem to
basically just have their own identity
Rhian movement and they seem almost
blind to the fact that they just have a
different flavor of the same thing that
they're criticizing the alt-right is a
really really good example that that
we've talked about do you think that
this is a deliberate sort of ignoring of
that double standard or do you think
they are genuinely blind to the reality
that they espouse a version of the same
identity politics they claim to call
destructive when it's the left well you
know I think that I would really reframe
that question because I don't think that
identity politics as they're what are
called identity politics are bad at all
I would say the opposite I say that
there's nothing wrong whatsoever with
the identity politics of the left which
are functionally just asking for equal
treatment for women LBGT people people
of color you know for allowing you know
immigrant communities to thrive things
like that completely and to be favored
clear I completely agree with you with
every every tenet that you've stated
there yeah so when I say that their
right-wing identity politics that's a
very different kind of claim that
they're making and they will often make
it obliquely right by using political
correctness as a cover story but really
the claim that they're making is that
white straight white male privilege
should not be you know challenged in any
way and and that they should retain all
the levers of power in society or at
least the majority of them when it comes
to free speech I see that there's sort
of a similar double standard or
hypocrisy we're sort of even seeing it
now with this Laura Ingraham advertiser
boycott that that we're seeing which is
the
claimed to be a movement all about the
Battle of ideas and no censorship and
getting all of the ideas out there and
sort of letting that debate be engaged
on within a free market of ideas where
nobody is limited in what they can say
but they seem to be against someone
saying I'm gonna use my speech to call
for a boycott of Laura Ingraham they
seem to be against private advertisers
saying hey you know what we can make
decisions about where we do and don't
want to advertise using whatever
barometer is important to us I see the
same double standard yeah and a lot of
troll nation really discusses the way
that the idea of political correctness
and the claims to be censored are mostly
bad faith arguments lies and and and
it's functionally I consider it a hoax
right I it it's it's a way for the right
to sort of once again position
themselves as victims as opposed to like
challenging the ideas like getting into
a real debate and I've written about
this at salon as well I think that a lot
of the time what you see on the right is
they will kind of create situations
where they can kind of pretend to be
victims of censorship so that they can
make the debate over free speech which
wasn't off which was generally not even
challenged in the first place instead of
actually talking about their ideas
because I think they know that their
ideas are repulsive and would never work
on their own but yeah absolutely there's
like an amazing amount of hypocrisy you
know you see it in the fact that they
get angry when there are protests of
right-wing speakers on campus even
though protest isn't it of itself a kind
of free speech and yet they you know
they say you know right-wing speakers
should be allowed to say whatever they
want which I you know tend to agree
that's not the issue here
short of direct incitement to violence I
completely agree yeah yeah but they you
know also have to put up with protest
and that is not you know violation their
free speech rights but then you see
Donald Trump flip around and demand that
the protet the the NFL players who are
kneeling to protest violence against
black people in this country should not
be allowed to do that well that's you
know a blatant call for censorship of
those men's free speech rights and their
attempt to probe
which the NFL you know was basically
kind of allowing to happen in the first
place I think that the this disconnect
is often that there's a group that
claims to be for free speech that sees
the consequences of speech as a
limitation on that speech when hard part
of free speech is that the speech can
have consequences and we're not talking
about violent consequences we're not
talking about the consequence being that
a government tells you that you cannot
speak or threatens to imprison you for
what you said but speech has
consequences protests count as those
consequences advertisers making business
decisions that's all just the freedom of
those individuals to express their
speech and I feel like that's where it
goes too far for many yeah and I think
that I cannot emphasize enough that most
of these right-wing arguments are being
made in like bad faith ok let me go glad
you're bringing that I want to go back
to that because I'm not I'm just not
sure about that like my mind is open I'm
willing to be convinced of that in my
experience I think that a lot of the
people not the people going around
making the arguments and getting all the
attention but the people participating
in reddit discussions and sending tweets
in this type of thing I actually don't
think they're making the arguments in
bad faith I think they've fallen for bad
arguments and that they actually believe
them whole cloth yeah that could be so
like obviously when I'm talking about
you know the riot it's it's my I I get
maybe it wasn't obvious but you know I
am trying to talk about like the
politicians and the pundits you know go
to set the tone you know but I think
like you know in the brooklet awk about
like milo gianopolous constant stunts
right and he he's trying to do this
thing where he goes onto campus and he
he wants the negative reaction he has
created situations where he was not
actually being censored but he would get
get himself caught up in red tape so
that he could declare that he was being
censored because being censored was the
point of it and if he wasn't gonna get
censored he was gonna try to create a
reason to claim that he was being
censored so that's like not only an act
of bad faith but like a really
overtly obvious act of bad faith when it
comes to the sort of what you describe
as Trump trolling attempts right the
coming up with the pejorative titles
like little Marco and crooked Hillary
that type of stuff when he starts with
the Rosie O'Donnell stuff and the megyn
kelly bleeding out of you know where
stuff do you characterize that as a form
of trolling do you think that Trump is
doing it deliberately or that he thinks
that that is sort of valid political
speech in some way like how should we
understand the use of that type of
material by the president you know out
of all the things that of all the
right-wing trolling I think that the
nasty nicknames probably is the least
offensive to me because it's kind of an
empty bit of just childish bullying
right yeah and and and obviously I think
people name call on both sides and I
think overall I don't find that to be
the most harmful aspect of all this I
think what's a lot more harmful is the
way that trolling harassing dogpiling
and culture war antics have sort of
eclipsed any and all efforts at having
like reasonable dialogue or discourse
about ideas period you know a lot of
what I argue in this book is that it's
turned into kind of just a politics of
demonization right and and you mentioned
the Laura Ingraham thing and I think
that's a really good example because
what they've been doing with these
Parkland kids is just shows how empty
like right-wing politics have gotten
they cannot get past they've gotten so
much in the habit of Douma of ad hominem
attacks by saying that liberals are
wrong because liberals are bad people
right that they can't get past it even
with these super sympathetic parkland
gun shooting violence survivors and she
she couldn't help but like try to make a
thing out of his college admissions you
know the fact that he had been denied to
go into UCLA what does that have to do
with gun violence almost absolutely
nothing and yet I don't think that the
right is capable anymore of actually
engaging arguments I think they can all
just shoot the messenger as it were
that's uh I mean are you concerned a
question I get often let me go at it
this way a question I get often from
people in my audience is if when Trump
goes right whether it's short of 2020 or
after a second term or resign who know
whenever whenever Trump goes is there
any undoing this sort of debasement of
the discourse that you're sort of
pointing out here or or is it sort of
now that the door has been open to it
being acceptable at least to a
significant part of the country to do
politics the way Trump did it during the
debates and even now is there any going
back from that and if so what undoes
this damage that's a really good
question and I really wish I had a
better answer part of I think what makes
this complicated is that this predates
Trump and it's not just Trump like Trump
I think is actually the culmination of a
series of events that has been going on
the American right for decades now
starting really with Rush Limbaugh and
Fox News where their argument sort of
came down to liberals are the enemy
defeat them at all costs mock them did
rate you know degrade them and and
really not just dealing with ideas at
all and and the end point was Donald
Trump right this man who doesn't have
any ideas of his own but he knows who he
hates
right and I think that if it was just
Trump it would be a lot easier to walk
it back he's gone we all just pretend
that didn't happen and we move on with
our lives right but that's that rut is
all the way through there the right in
this country you know being a right
winger isn't about having a set of
ideals anymore it's about hating
liberals and wanting to piss them off at
any you know at all at all cost and I
think that I don't know how we're gonna
walk that back I mean I think whoever's
gonna run after Trump is going to have
to either Trump is gonna make it so bad
that this it becomes an actual wake-up
call but that's gonna have to be on
Republicans themselves because we on the
Left can't do anything about that I
would say that which is like
is it sort of up to Republicans in their
next primary to figure out whether this
is the new normal or not yeah and I mean
it's hard to say i mean even mitt
romney's campaign was a little bit empty
wasn't it I mean you think about like
Donald Trump I mean giving stupid
nicknames to people is just a more
childish version of Mitt Romney making
this very empty argument that 47% of
Americans are takers not makers right
and I I think that it's very difficult
because I can't even a point to a
politician on the right now who I think
has ideas that he could campaign on and
win and it's it's a troubling very
troubling trend I mean you know my ideal
would be that it just means that
Democrats completely crushed the next
few elections but I also am NOT that big
an optimist absolutely and I think
people who now are seeing Trump's
approval in the 40s mathematically Trump
can win with the voter turnout that we
have Trump can win with an approval in
the high 20s and that is partially just
the way the system is sort of set up so
one of my at least going into 2018 one
of my biggest messages is no matter what
you think is going on in the Senate
races or congressional races in your
state or district just just go out and
vote because even with very low turnout
mildly unpopular people can can very
easily get elected yeah I mean I would
concur a million times I think that you
know it's clear that the Republican
Party right now is structured around
finding a way to maintain minority rule
without actually having to come up with
ideas that please the public that get
them elected on ideas even through
gerrymandering or these sort of politics
of resentment and fear and you know I
think that our only hope of winning is
being very clear-eyed about that yeah
the book is troll nation we've been
speaking with amanda marcotte who's a
senior political writer for salon.com
amanda great to talk to you I appreciate
it thank you thanks for having me